if we were going to do the if we knew
then what we know now 2012 draft who
goes first to the colts andrew luck or
russell wilson oh that is a really good
question mike oh gosh
um
man well i mean if we knew what we knew
now and we know like you know it's hard
to do that just off a blank slate uh but
of course russell wilson's been healthy
and andrew luck missed a year of
football so i would probably give
russell wilson the edge in that
department but russell had also had the
benefit of growing into what he is now
as a player because he had a great
support system you know i know
everyone's going to look at andrew luck
and go well he went to the playoffs the
first few years yeah but those teams
weren't that good and it was a lot about
andrew luck hanging in the pocket and
making big time plays and that's why his
body got beat to crap but uh wilson also
to his defense had to grow up playing a
style of football that was defense
running the ball hey russell don't take
any chances
you know don't turn the ball over he has
to play for a defensive head coach and
that's not always easy as a quarterback
and i give him credit for that for the
numbers that he puts up consistently on
a year-to-year basis
i still think it would be luck and i
look at it this way if you put luck if
you put luck on the seahawks since 2012
yeah i i yeah i think think about it it
was it was the defense that carried that
team early on you had andrew luck to the
mix with the team that he would have had
around him and i know the offensive line
has been suspect there but it was
suspect in indianapolis and he was still
pretty damn good and i think it would
have been easier for an andrew luck to
walk into the seahawks locker room and
be accepted it was a struggle for
russell wilson think about it richard
sherman his former college teammate
would have been there andrew luck and
richard sherman would have had a better
relationship right out of the gate doug
baldwin richard sherman and russell
wilson ever had so i think andrew luck
in seattle would have been as successful
if not more successful than russell
wilson so i still think luck before
wilson if that choice were made all over
again but some of the names of the guys
drafted before russell wilson and i know
it's inexact but but my god the guy
lasted until pick 75. robert griffin
trent richardson justin blackman matt
khalil just in the first just in the top
ten right he's got morris claiborne mark
but ryan tannehill miami dolphins you
could have had russell wilson we were
talking yesterday about how hey the
dolphins should call the seahawks if
they don't work out this deal in seattle
for wilson they could have had him with
the eighth overall pick but it was that
stigma of the small quarterback that
wilson has overcome in a major way and
now he will make
157 million over the next five years
there's a no trade clause in this
contract
and wilson uh again i don't know how
long it's gonna last but he's the
highest paid player in nfl history and
he will
he will hold that four i think you know
until either patrick i probably until
patrick mahomes whenever that deal is
done whether it's right after the 2019
season before the 2020 season whenever
my home signs his next contract that's
when wilson goes back to being number
two yeah that's right he's got he's got
about 11 months march of 2020 he's done
mahomes will be the the king there what
i would really be interested to know
just with all the stuff we've heard you
know russell wilson you know i'm gonna
have a deadline the seattle seahawks and
you know some of the rumors we've heard
there and the jackdel rio comments from
last week and everything that's kind of
swirled around this conversation colin
cowherd you brought that up about him
here in new york all that
i would love to know and i know uh you
know paul allen is no longer with us but
i believe it's his sister right mike
that's running the team now am i correct
with that um i just want to know i
wonder if they got involved in this a
little bit and we're like hey cut out
the nonsense he's our guy let's go get
it done he's the franchise going forward
i just wonder if ownership got involved
or gotten the ear of a john schneider
and pete carroll in this and overruled
them a little bit or were john schneider
and pete carroll going down this road no
matter what i would love to know that
aspect of it i don't know that at this
time but
these are the type of decisions that
owners usually do get very involved in
yeah and and look i mean whatever the
owner's position you learn a lot about
an owner based upon what he or she does
in a situation like this do you do you
defer to your football people or do you
step in and say pay what it takes to get
this deal done i don't care we need this
guy we can't afford a reality where
we're going year to year where maybe he
will leave i mean look the bottom line
is he's staying he's recommitted to
seattle but i think there was one hell
of a poker face that was attached by him
and by his agent mark rogers because
they scared seattle seattle believed he
wanted to play elsewhere and the report
that peter king had yesterday that it
was now or never that if they didn't do
a long-term deal as of yesterday for
russell wilson he was never signing
another long-term contract with the
seahawks ever again if that is the
message it was being communicated to the
seahawks that's why they thought he was
intent on playing elsewhere if you're
never going to sign a long-term contract
if this window closes without one but
they got it done he's staying put he's
happy to be there and and good job by
mark rogers and russell wilson to sell
this idea that they were playing
hardball because i think you don't get
the 35 million a year in new money if
you don't scare the crap out of the
seahawks that's right and i don't i
understand him playing hardball because
i think he's also sitting there there
going wait i mean since i've been here
we go to the playoffs every year i make
magic happen in the fourth quarter no
matter what every game we're down by 12.
we're down by 14. we might not come back
to win it but i'm russell wilson and
we're in the conversation for maybe
pulling it off almost every fourth
quarter because of the magic he can do
so he makes a deadline because he's
going come on you guys have seen me for
seven freaking years now i mean how much
more do you have to see you don't think
i'm the guy there's better options out
there so um you know again the the
continue
continuing of the knowledge of business
aspect so that the the nfl player is uh
you know growing in that department if
i'm making sense there is impressive i
mean i just think we're seeing a lot of
players lately make some really
hard-line business decisions to get the
maximum amount of dollars or get the
most out of their situation and good for
russell wilson for doing that in this
instance
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports